onze ans après sa mise en service
commercial concorde continue aujourd'hui
à desservir quotidiennement la ligne
paris new york en un peu plus de trois
heures
pour cela trois avions et trois
équipages sont chaque jour nécessaire
car si à paris ou à new york le vol
régulier à un problème technique
un autre concorde prend aussitôt la
place 18 mètres d'altitude un ciel bleu
nuit une vitesse supérieure à deux fois
celle du sang un allongement de trois
centimètres pendant le vol dues au
frottement de l'air concorde est le seul
avion commercial au monde qu'ils fassent
toujours rêver pourtant avec la crise du
transport aérien de la fin des années 70
air france a dû réduire de sept à quatre
le nombre des concordes exploiter de
l'est supersonique servant de pièces
détachées ou 4 valide mais aujourd'hui
avec le renouveau d'engouement pour
concorde
on assiste au phénomène inverse les cinq
supersonique en service ne suffisent
plus à répondre à la demande des vols
charters nous avons enregistré en
l'année 1986 une croissance très
importante qui nous ravit des vols
chartered du concorde puisque nous en
avons fait 125 125 cette année c'est une
croissance presque je dis pas
géométriques en fait très rapide et nous
pensons qu'ils vont encore se développer
nous avons commencé les tours du monde
avec american express à la fin de
l'année passée nous avons déjà quatre
tours du monde programmée pour l'année
qui vient
un cinquième qui se profile donc nous
pensons qu'il y a là une possibilité de
développement du concorde ces vols
spéciaux font - plus de 20 % des heures
de vols à l'heure actuelle
juste revanche de cet avion entre
longtemps décrié qui a pourtant
aujourd'hui encore une avance
technologique de 10 ans un succès qui
relance désormais l'idée d'un
supersonique de deuxième génération pour
la fin des années 90